now one of the big question marks of the
last year has been
who will actually be running the show in
any biden-harris administration
obviously biden himself can't carry the
burden of the presidency
he can't even get through a weekend with
his dog
but someone has to call the shots it's
now
obvious that on the three topics of
foreign policy
trade policy and china areas where the
trump administration
charted a bold new course the real power
in a biden administration
would be tony blinken his pick for
secretary of state
how will joe biden as a president view
china
partner competitor rival enemy what and
how
probably some combination of all the
things you just said
how profound now let me get this
straight first biden says that china
is not a threat then his pick for
secretary of state
says they're almost partners with us
what's next president xi helps decorate
the white house christmas tree next year
so what are blinken's plans now if you
saw my back and forth last night with
doug
shone you'll know that his agenda is
marked above
everything else by the notion that
america must
never ever do anything on its own
here's a quote from blinken we are not
the leader of first choice because we're
always right or because we're
universally liked
it is because we can strive to the best
of our ability to align our actions
with our principles and because our
leadership holds the ability
to mobilize others and make a difference
now let's look at this quotation
carefully now the first sentence simply
assures us that america's power doesn't
come from the righteousness of its cause
uh the appeal of its political system or
its economic and political might
okay can you imagine washington or
lincoln or fdr
or reagan or of course trump talking
about america
in such a dismissive way well so far so
bad
of course though it does echo one of our
previous leaders
there have been times where america has
shown arrogance
and been dismissive even derisive
that the americans are not your enemy we
sometimes make mistakes
we have not been perfect so we've made
our share of mistakes some restoration
of america's standing in the world the
united states is still working through
some of our
own darker periods in our history
well the biden dark winter is just
beginning
but i digress what does mr blinken see
as america's strengths well first he
says that
we strive to the best of our ability to
align our actions with our principles
well a statement is just diplo
meaningless speak
every government seeks to align its
actions with its principles
president xi does this in china so does
mayor de blasio of course in new york
so does albus dumbledore at hogwarts
the second great strength of america and
the only real one according to mr
blanken's quote is that
our leadership holds the ability to
mobilize others and make a difference
so according to him america acting alone
counts for nothing we're only important
if we can
mobilize others now so we didn't win the
cold war
with troops or money we simply mobilized
others
the protesters in hong kong this summer
they did not wave american flags because
they believed in our ideal of freedom
they were just happy that we have other
countries on speed dial apparently
but what if other countries refuse to be
mobilized
what if heaven forbid they actually put
their interests
ahead of ours for decades the same tired
voices proposed the same failed
solutions
pursuing global ambitions at the expense
of their own people
but only when you take care of your own
citizens
will you find a true basis for
cooperation
for example what if mr blinken asked the
europeans for help on china
and they say no stuff it what if he
asked them to put pressure on iran
and they refuse well i guess he's out of
options because his only power
the power to mobilize others won't
always work
blinking is essentially announcing the
world that we will never act
unilaterally
we'll depend on the goodwill of other
countries
well this has been tried before
america can't do this alone the afghan
people
need our troops and your troops our
support and your support
the future that we are building together
not
separately and that starts right here in
europe
the people of europe are more secure and
more prosperous
because we stood together for the ideals
we share the europeans
held the obama administration in such
low
esteem that they did nothing of any
significance to help obama with china
the japanese and other asian countries
signed the trans-pacific partnership
but that deal was so bad so bad for the
united states
and so favorable to other countries even
hillary clinton
had no choice but to oppose it
now one thing we know about foreign
policy is that everyone knows how to
take advantage of a sucker
so when blinking tries to mobilize the
eu against china
he'll have to sacrifice our trade policy
to please eu bureaucrats at the wto to
even get a hearing
he'll trade american jobs by eliminating
the tariffs put in place
by president trump which he has already
previewed
does trump have a point that there is a
systematic uh set of
predatory practices that europeans have
to have
enacted he has a point on specific uh
products
and industries but starting a trade war
with our closest allies is not the way
to make that point and to make it
effectively
uh he's now started a race to the bottom
well blinken will put israel and the
entire middle east at risk by doing what
europe wants on iran
and giving the mullahs a free hand and
some mad money
this is what he said about the obama
administration's nuclear deal
that trump pulled us out of that's made
us safer
made countries around the world safer
part of that involved lifting
sanctions on iran and that freed up
money that had been frozen around the
world
that iran had in bank accounts that it
couldn't bring back to iran the
overwhelming majority of that money
is going into their economy which is in
dire straits it's not going how do we
know that's right
we know blinking knows how dare you
question him
and chyna blinken will get a hero's
welcome in beijing
he won't be as tough on china as trump
has been he's tried to stir up anger
toward china
around the world he's tried to destroy
china in this way
i think it's good for the world that
biden has won
biden and his globalist lackeys will
pour new investments into china
energizing its efforts to become the
most powerful country on earth
and as china gets stronger and we get
weaker
we must make lincoln's peace through
surrender policy
a major issue going forward including in
the georgia senate race
i don't believe that the people of
georgia want to give up on american
sovereignty
and leave themselves wholly dependent on
the goodwill of the europeans
the canadians or any other country for
that matter
the confirmation hearing for blinken
must feature sharp
and focused questioning from republicans
who challenge
his follow the world foreign policy and
then as the inevitable results of
lincoln and biden's failed approach
become manifest
we can go back to the country let's say
in 2022
2024 and seek a return to common sense
and a renewed focus on our national
interest
and that's the angle